Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
Remember you can add your questions to the Zoom
prior to the Zoom member site or go ahead and chat into your question if you're thinking of what
right now and then I'll get to that. We'll get through these questions. Also remember check your
announcements for any new announcements and you can self-schedule any appointments, multiple places.
Okay, let's get back to the questions. First question, back in the 1980s, I heard about colostrum
being used to combat cancer. Has that still been used?
No, there are some cancers that don't do well with colostrum. I actually wrote an article about this
if you search the blog for colostrum and cancer, I think that's what the title of the article is
called, but it just talks about the pros and cons of colostrum. Usually I say most cancer patients
don't have a problem using colostrum. They want to help with their hair or their nails or something
like that, but it's not considered at all a cancer treatment any longer. There's pros and cons to
colostrum. It can accelerate growth in some cancers and there's some data that it can help with
people with cancer. So there's a lot of mixed data about colostrum out there. And I don't think it's
you know, there's a lot of data that's out there that's very biased, but I don't think it's unbiased.
I don't think it's biased. I think there's cause to be concerned about using excess colostrum
with cancer patients, especially if it's an epithelial cell cancer, like a colon cancer or something
like that. If a person had a lymphoma or something, I don't think there's any harm in using colostrum,
but you could check out that article on our blog. Is there a program on the right for anti-histamine
for someone that has high histamine problems? If so, can I add it to my program? Well, there really
isn't a program to lower histamine. There is programming for inflammation and that's what histamine
elevated histamine does is it causes that's part of the whole inflammatory cascade.
Is it a release of histamine and other inflammatory markers? But there isn't a
program specifically that's going to decrease histamine, so no. You can use the general inflammation
programs, but there's no histamine program, so sorry about that. There are so many modalities to help
fight cancer cells and bring the body back into balance. How much or how many could I be doing
along with what I'm currently doing? Could I add hyperthermia or CBD oil?
So yeah, there are. There are a lot of anti-cancer therapies as far as nutritional approaches.
There are a lot of, you know, approaches using off-label drugs. There's approaches using other
physical modalities like hyperthermia, so let's talk about a few of those. Now part of the reason
why we do the cheek swab testing and developing a protocol for a person is that we're trying to
help that person not feel like they're they have to try everything that they hear about and then
they find themselves on 27 different protocols taking 48 different vitamins four times a day.
I think too much of a good thing can be a bad thing, so just because
bend is all might be good for one person doesn't mean everybody should be on bend is all just because
you know, proto-cell might be good for one person doesn't mean everybody should be taking proto-cell.
You cannot physically do all of that and furthermore, if you did physically do all of that,
it could actually make you worse because your liver has to detoxify what your body can't use.
So if you're going to take things and your body and you absorb them, you're going to take extra
nutrients and your body is absorbing it and your body isn't needing it to help combat your
disease or your cancer or whatever you're dealing with, it still has to detoxify through your liver
detox pathway. So you could be doing more harm than good, overwhelming your liver detox pathways by
trying too many things, especially things that you're going to be taking orally. Now different modalities
like oh, while I heard about hyperbaric oxygen is good, so I'm going to go run out and buy a
hyperbaric oxygen chamber. I heard hypertherbias good, so I'm going to get a hypertherbia unit. I heard
cryotherapy is good, so I'm going to get a cryotherapy tub. Saunas are good, so we're going to get
this. There's a balance of which everybody has to make that decision. That is a big reason why
our philosophy of writing rife programs that you're mainly doing at night while you're sleeping,
you can't do hyperbaric oxygen while you're sleeping, you can't do hypertherbia while you're sleeping,
you can't do PEMF while you're sleeping, but you can certainly do the rife while you're sleeping.
Now that frees you up to maybe decide to add another therapy if you have the wherewithal to do so
during the day. Now when would a person choose to do a specific therapy? It partly greatly depends
on that type of cancer that that person has. So if a person has, let's use hypertherbia as an example,
if a person has breast cancer is localized hypertherbia, a good choice for care.
Yes, it's an excellent choice for care for breast cancer. How about for liver cancer? Yeah,
how about for pancreatic cancer? Yes. How about for lymphoma? No, no. How about for leukemia? No, not really
no. Localized hypertherbia, because there's two different types of hypertherbia. So systemic hypertherbia
is where you're trying to raise your body temperature systemically. Now the truth is without
going to a German cancer clinic and being sedated, medically sedated with drugs and put into a
hypertherbia chamber for eight hours, you're not going to really be able to raise your core temperature
to to to the degree that it's really going to kill cancer cells. It's doing so does a hypertherbia.
Yeah, that's course. It's a hypertherbia. It's increased temperature. Is it
cancer killing? Not really. Is it help with detoxification pathways? Yes, absolutely. So that
would be a therapy to add. But it's not necessarily a cancer killing therapy. You know, localized
hypertherbia with the hypertherbia units that we use and sell. That would be a good therapy
for local hypertherbia. But it would be cancer type specific. Like I said, not a therapy for a
blood cancer, not a therapy for even a solitary, solitary lymphoma or for deep cancers. But for
superficial cancers, breast cancer, things like that, it can be a great choice.
And then CBD oil. You mentioned CBD oil. CBD is another one of those therapies that can be
a great addition for a lot of people. Now, some people do better with CBD than other people. So,
again, when we're talking about CBD, we have to make sure we're defying our terms correctly. CBD oil
by definition has no THC in it or very little THC in it. And it's the benefits of the CBD. Now,
is that a CBD going to be a cancer killer or any cancer? The answer is no. Are there other benefits
of CBD? It helps decrease inflammation in the brain. It can help with systemic inflammation.
You have cannabinoid receptors in every part of your body in every organ. Can it be
harmful for the health of your tissues and the health of your organs? Sure, can't
did everybody be taking CBD? No, I mean, it's just a matter of you could say so many good things
about literally every single nutrient on the planet. But does that mean everybody should be taking it?
No, the other thing when people say CBD for cancer, they're really talking about THC. So,
THC is a totally different therapy for cancer. It has a lot of positives, but it has a lot of
negatives. So, there have noticed that when I put these questions in the slides, there was another
question about Rixins and Oil or the THC therapy for cancer. So, I'll save that when that comes up.
Oh, here it is. Can you explain RSO? So, when you look up RSO, I don't know if you can see it on
Google anymore, you might have to go to an alternate platform. RSOs, first of all, as cancer therapy
goes, stands for Rixins and Oil. Rixins and Oil is a high grade THC, which is the psychoactive
part of the marijuana plant or the hemp plant that is the psychoactive component of that is the THC.
Concentrated super concentrated THC is what's called Rixins and Oil and it comes in a syringe because
it's literally the consistency of a black tar. And it has been shown to be effective in helping kill
cancer cells taken at the right dosage. And the right dosage is measured in what's called grains
of rice. Now, it is equal to one gram, I believe, per day, but it's three grains of rice three times
a day. Now, that is enough THC to knock anybody out and to make you really, really super loopy.
That does not make you feel good while you're doing the Rixins and Protocol. It's a three-month protocol.
Once you get up to that dosage, and I have not known anyone that has enjoyed it. It just completely
wipes you out. You can't really function during the day. But it was a protocol that was very big a
number years ago until the FDA came up against anybody that had anything about Rixins and Oil on their
website, which they came after. Austin Such as well. We had to pull anything that was CBD or THC related
off of our website. And even about CBD, even though it has zero psychoactive residue in it,
most scrubbed CBD. Most supplement companies are staying away from making it a matter of fact,
number of supplement companies that used to make it have stopped making it and stopped selling it
because even though ironically how it's THC marijuana is more as getting state licensure across the
United States and it's now legal, basically, to sell it anywhere instead of having to give it the
black market. The FDA is even coming down on any company that's scrutinizing any company much
more closely if they're selling THC, even CBD products. So companies like Designs for Health and
Zybogen and things that were big name, supplement companies have discontinued all their CBD products
because they got threatened by the FDA or what, that they were going to, you know,
everything else was going to be scrutinized, even tighter. They've all pulled all their products.
It's really kind of sad how the drug industry is controlling everything. So Rick Simpson Oil is a very,
very concentrated THC component of the marijuana plant, can't use hemp, you have to use marijuana
to produce it. It's like a black tarry paste. You take it orally, usually some people have put it
in capsules and used it as a suppository, but you're getting less benefit from it.
But the downside is is that it's what it makes you feel most people cannot tolerate the protocol.
If I'm supposed to be off dairy for my cancer, can I still eat some butter? Probably one of the
most common questions we get. If I'm supposed to be off dairy for my cancer, can I still eat some butter?
So understand, when we test you, we're testing you for what we believe is a food driver to your cancer.
So if dairy comes up as a food driver to your cancer, you want to not eat dairy.
But it's within balance. We're not talking about you having dairy antibodies to
proteins to k-seed. We're not talking about a food sensitivity that if you eat it, you're
going to have this horrible reaction and you get sick. Though, are we talking about if you eat a
little butter that your cancer is going to take off and grow? Though, when it tests as a driver
for your cancer, you want to cut out like 95% of that if possible. So, okay, where would I be getting
more growth factors from a dairy product by putting a little butter on my toast or whatever I'm eating
or by eating a bowl of ice cream? Well, pretty simple answer to that. So when you're off of a food
because it's a driver to the cancer, it's not, this isn't a cult, this isn't a religion,
your, does it mean that dairy, you know, butter is probably a much better choice than the butter
substitutes out there. But, you know, cheese and how about the cheese substitutes? Well, I don't know,
there's a lot of credit in cheese too, even if you didn't have dairy as an issue. But it's so
stayed off of something you're trying to eliminate 90 to 95% of that thing in your diet to decrease
a fee, the fuel source for the cancer so things slow down. So to answer the question, yeah, you could
still eat some butter. Should you eat it like it's going out of style? Probably not, but it's
better than probably better than the butter substitutes. It's all about balance. So, not trying to make
this a, you know, an idol in your life with your diet or anything you're doing, you're trying to,
you know, take a reasonable approach to help your body fight this. Last week, you advised that I
pulse the fed bendisol in my JTP product. So that's the Joe Tippen's protocol due to the out of range
labs of creatine and estimated glomerular filtration rate on my lab. So I paused it for a week now,
subsequently I've learned that the dosages that I was on was much higher than normal. And maybe
it's advisable to for me to cut the dosages in half. And maybe my I've erected dose is also an issue.
I've been taking 225 milligrams of fed bendisol twice a day and 32 milligrams of I've erected twice a day
on five days off two days. I think they are higher than what I was seeing in other places. These are
closer to turbo cancer doses that some people give. I was also curious why you looked at fed
bendisol as a culprit to pause rather than the Ivermectin since the fed bendisol to 25 milligram
dosages for a 10 pound dog. And I'm 155 pounds around 75 kilograms. Okay, so let's go back to dosages
of fed bendisol and or Ivermectin for somebody with cancer. So the typical Joe Tippen's protocol for
fed bendisol is 225 milligrams once a day three days on four days off and continuing on that cycle.
Now there's people that have much more aggressive cancer and they're doing 440 milligrams per day
of fed bendisol three days on four days off. And there's people that are taking it even more
aggressive approach and they're doing 444 milligrams twice a day every day of the week. And there's
people that are taking it even more aggressive approach and they're up to 888. So they're taking four
packets of fed bendisol every day, every day of the week. So it depends on where the person is at.
So again, I would agree if your cancer isn't being aggressive right now, if you feel great and you
don't feel like you're in a more crisis state, then you should probably drop back to the standard
protocol of fed bendisol, which is 222 milligrams of fed bendisol once per day.
And then a person again would titrate up on that dosage based upon how
their aggressiveness or their cancer, how aggressive they want to be with it and keep in mind that
you're running kidney and liver function tests on a very regular basis to make sure that you're
not having issues with detoxification pathways and elevated AST, ALT, alkaline phosphates,
creatinine and EGFR like you had. So you're looking at kidney function tests, you're looking at
liver function tests. So why was I say that fed bendisol has a greater chance of being the culprit
of affecting your kidney function test and liver function test. It's just my historical
data that I have seen patients over a period of time and see what's the greater chance of
having an effect as a fed bendisol, a negative effect to liver markers and kidney markers as
a fed bendisol or hyperbendisol. And again, so what could be raising your kidney markers could be
the fed bendisol, could be the hyperbendisol, could be neither one of those, right? Could be something
else. So how would you know that? Well, you could just pulse off one and see if those numbers go back
into normal and go back on the other, but you were just making that guess. As far as the dose
of ivermectin, the standard dose of ivermectin that has been used out there. Okay, so let's go from
the simplest, the simplest dose of ivermectin that was used to help prevent
like COVID or something like that was typically just three milligrams of ivermectin
not based upon weight, three milligrams ivermectin per day. If you had COVID or were thought you were
exposed to COVID or you were, you know, in the middle of COVID, people were taking 12 milligrams
ivermectin per day, not based on weight. But with cancer, it's based upon weight and it's based
upon your kilogram weight. So you got to just below your handy calculator on your computer,
how do I convert my weight in pounds to kilograms, this person converted their weight to kilograms,
they weigh about 75 kilograms. So the standard beginning dose of ivermectin for cancer is half
a milligram per kilogram weight. So if you weigh 75 kilograms, let's half of 75, 37.5. So you'd
start off by taking 37.5 milligrams ivermectin per day, 37.5 per day would be the mildest dose.
And then you'd tight trade up. So depending again, if you're really ill and you really need to fight
this, you got stage 4 cancer, you need to be really active fighting this, you get you'd start at that
37.5. And then after you're able to tolerate that, several weeks go by, you move up to
1 milligram per kilogram dose, which if you weigh 75 kilograms, you now be taking 75 milligrams per
day, 75 milligrams per day. And then you can move up to 1.5 milligrams per kilogram weight,
and up to two milligrams per kilogram weight. So the maximum dose of somebody at 75 kilograms
would be 150 milligrams, or excuse me, 150 milligrams of ivermectin per day. Hope that helps. So
it's really not too busy when you just sit down and do the math with it. I wonder about these
blood labs as I don't recall you mentioning them, and I hadn't even heard of most of them.
IL-1, IL-6, IL-8, and serioplasm for inflammation. Vege F-TF-G-B, I think it's T-G-B-F beta.
F-G-B-I-G-F-1, HER2, and copper for progression or bats. I know some functional medicine docs have
been running D-diverse, and it's COVID for cardiovascular health. Is that useful for cancer too?
So these markers are all inflammatory markers.
Interleukin 1, interleukin 6, interleukin 8. There's a bunch of different inflammatory cycle,
what are called cytokines that start with interleukin. Serioplasm is your main carrier for copper
in your body. Vege F is vascular endothelial growth factor. These are chemokines. These two.
So as this one is a chemokine slash cytokine. This is a growth factor intermediate.
So why would a cancer clinic run these tests? So you're looking, these are inflammatory cytokines.
There's also anti-inflammatory cytokines. So these IL-1, IL-6, and IL-8 are part of the TH-1
immune system. So your immune system can be separated into a couple different classifications.
So as far as how your immune system affects the rest of your body as far as inflammation goes,
there's the inflammatory immune response, which is the T helper 1 response. Now that's mainly part of
your initial immune response. So if you have an infection, you have inflammation at that side of the
infection because it's bringing in these initial responders are chemokines and cytokines that will
initiate that response to draw lymphocyte family into the area to kill possible infections. So you
slice your arm open with a knife and it becomes infected and red there so that it's causing this
immune response to draw lymphocytes and macrophages to the area to kill any infection that's how you
prevent dying from a blood infection with an injury. But you get an elevation of these cytokines for
other inflammatory events. That's why I'm very big on getting food sensitivity testing and chemical
sensitivity testing and things like that because if you're exposed to an enormous amount of toxic
chemicals, you're going to have an inflammatory event. If you're exposed to foods that you have
antibodies against, that's going to cause an inflammatory event. So that's not good when you got
this systemic inflammation. So these are part of the TH1 cascade. There's other ones too that are not
listed here. But these are inflammatory cytokines. They could do damage long-term
by blocking one's ability to kill cancer cells. So one of the things that builds up on the outside
of a growing cancer is this one, interleukin 6. So interleukin 6 is inflammatory and it can be a waste
product from rapidly replicating cells. So getting rid of this would be a good thing. That's why you
take curcumin. That's why you take green T-E-G-C-G and resveratrol and the flavonoids that decrease
inflammation. You're trying to decrease inflammation in other things that you're eating. You're trying to
talk to somebody about their labs the other day. They had a lot of different toxicities. The idea is
that we're trying to clean up our physical environments so that we could not be exposed to any toxins. But
that any time you can lower your dosage of toxicity, you're going to decrease the overall inflammatory
process in your body and you're going to be able to use your immune cells to kill other things like
infections and cancers instead of dealing with chemicals and food sensitivities and other reasons
why we are becoming inflamed. It even gets worse if you have antibodies to self-tissue
aka an autoimmune disease because every time you are exposed to some trigger that causes inflammation
you're going to also kill your healthy cells and your tissues as well. As far as seruloplasm,
seruloplasm is one of the things that we look at the genes that we look at when we look at your
genetics because if you have a lot of defects with that it's really easy to get a build-up
of copper and what's called a copper toxicity. A copper toxicity is actually quite common. People
think they need to be taking copper, I see videos on Instagram about using copper bracelets and
using copper pans because copper is so good for you. Those people do not know what they're talking
about. You're exposed to a lot of copper. If you eat a decent diet you're getting more copper than
what you need in order for your cells to survive and your hopefully your body is doing a good job
getting rid of excess copper. Some people with genetic issues don't do that very well and they end
up with a copper toxicity which causes a whole slurry of cascade of issues that a person could have
and don't know that I've never tested anybody and it'd be the cause of cancer. But one of the things
that habit excess copper does is it decreases your zinc. Copper and zinc go together in your tissues
and you can measure a copper zinc ratio in your blood to get an idea. Though it's not perfect
you get an idea of where that person's at with copper. So I don't want my cancer patients taking
supplements with copper in them. We don't want excess copper. Copper is a growth factor piece
and excess copper causes you know inability to detoxify other things and it pushes out zinc
and zinc is necessary for the immune response and it's necessary to help kill cancer.
So veg F is different. Vascular endothelial growth factor can be measured with a blood test as well
and why would you measure that? Because excess veg F is not good for cancer.
Well it's different for blood cancers like leukemia or multiple bioloba but it is not good for any
solid cancer. So if you have an increase in vascular endothelial growth factor you have an increase in
growth of blood vessels which is actually what you would want to do. You'd want to do things that
would increase veg F. You'd want to take supplements that would increase veg F. If you did not have
cancer and you had heart issues, heart disease, you know, early heart disease, heart disease in your
family. You'd want to do things that increase veg F which would be like taking nitric oxide supplements.
You know doing you know a lot of exercising, aerobic type exercising is going to increase veg F.
Doing long fasts like more than a couple day fast is going to increase veg F. It's also going to
increase IGF1 which is another growth factor. So if you don't have cancer it's good to increase IGF1.
It's good to increase veg F but if you do have cancer you don't want to do things to increase
veg F and IGF1 because you'll increase the growth of blood vessels in the tumor thereby you know
allowing food sources to get in the tumor. So the tumor is growing from the center out and it's
growing those are rapidly growing tumors. So you want to do things that decrease veg F that
decrease IGF1 that decrease copper levels so but okay so then you go well good I should run these
labs Dr. Cutters why don't you have everybody run these labs? I don't see that in in your choices
for labs to run and the reason is is that okay so we already we're all know that we have inflammation
different sites you're not always going to have an elevated inflammatory markers in the blood
as far as cytokines cytokines are going to be processed quite quickly through the liver they're not
going to stay in the blood they're going to stay in the tissues and cause inflammation of the tissues
we already know that's there we don't need to measure that so I don't see any need to measure
cytokines in the blood and the reason why those tests exist is that if you think this person has
an acute poison either something they're rushed to the hospital with an ER we don't know what's wrong
with them they're super sick they don't have a fever we run a CBC they don't have any elevated CBC
blood markers what is going on you could run cytokine tests to see if they have some acute inflammatory
response to something like they were poisoned with arsenic as far as using them from a functional
medicine perspective to say this person has inflammation I don't really see a value in that
because the truth is from a metabolism standpoint cytokines are processed quickly through the
liver and guess what the byproduct of processed cytokines in the liver is it's what was called
what we call c-reactive protein so if a person has chronic inflammation that is being processed well
they will have an elevated c-reactive protein or another test is what's called high sensitivity
c-reactive protein used to be called cardiac c-reactive protein but c-reactive protein in general is
the sign of inflammation doesn't say where we don't know where it is we don't know what it's from but
there's inflammation that's present but it goes deeper than that remember every blood test is
a clue it's a hint it's a it's a it's pointing a flashlight at something for you to look a little
deeper into something a person could have a whole bunch of other signs of inflammation of their body
and not have elevated c-reactive protein so there's other things that you could look for is their
fairytale level increases their sen-right changed is there you know there's other things that
you're looking for and certainly you're not just looking at the objective blood testers other
objective findings and subjective findings that would point you towards that differential diagnosis
so I don't run these tests well why don't you run Vegef or IGF1 there's a way to run them
because you can't really you know you can't really change the nearly time you'd maybe run this test
is that the person is doing you know you know has heart serious heart disease at the same time they're
dealing with cancer so they're taking nitric oxide for their heart disease and you want to make sure
that it's not causing progression of the cancer so you've made run this test for those reasons but
as far as what you're going to be able to do to change these numbers it's it's not it's me it's not
of value to spend the money on these tests I mean we could if you know if we had endless
pockets we could run a zillion different labs but you know it's it's I'd rather have a person spend
their money in the correction in their in of their overall health and doing the things we know we
should do anyhow and like the question before maybe spend the money on getting a pdf or spend the
money on getting a localized hyperthermia or a sauna or something like that then running these labs
because you still have to do that do the work to you know to to move your body into reinstating
holostasis anyhow so why don't we just do that work just get to be expensive so that is the main reason
why I don't run this you have a study posted on the homepage of the member site talking about the
mitochondrial stem cell connection with cancer the abstract mentions a protocol there are
any links to more info or commentary of this study wondering what your thoughts are
okay I should put a little summary on there or something but that study was the study that showed
that Ivermectid and Fenn Bendisaw the different pathways that the metabolic pathways and how they
worked to and it was studied moving that those off-label drugs work to help kill cancer so that's why I
posted that main page of that study I did you know the study has I don't know how many pages I didn't
post all those pages but that was the main page of that study that proved Ivermectid and Fenn Bendisaw
worked with cancer and showed the different pathways on how it worked there's other studies that
show the different pathways on how those things work and I think we talked about that last week how
what are the major pathways that I was excited about is that it upregulated the p53 tumor suppressor
gene so it causes your body to be able to kill the cancer through the intrinsic apoptotic pathway
which that is a common issue when a person you know it has a cancer why can't their body kill it
because they have defects on tumor suppressor genes and they're basically not getting any help
from the intrinsic apoptotic pathway so you're having to try to kill it from the outside
instead of from the inside out so that's what that studies for it's referencing the information
right above that on the member site about Fenn Bendisaw and Ivermectid is there a good multivitimate
for my family to take okay this has been a tough question for a very long time it's actually just
recently but I was going to make a video of this supplement but I didn't I should make it it's a
new supplement we started carrying from aloe vea and I caught up because I don't I think it's called
vitality let me look it up and and the reason why I said it's a hard question to
answer is that number one so many supplements out there are have so many synthetic nutrients in it
which I don't like and then there are supplements that now you know about eight years ago and
methylation came into the knowledge of the of the naturopathic world which I think was a great crime
how it's been so misused but then you know there's methylated B12 methylated folate in it
in all the better supplements which can be way too many methyl groups for a little kid
and some of the other supplements out there are just garbage you know they have cyanokoboluminated
for the B12 and they have you know calcium carbonated you know I made multiple videos on how to recognize
bad supplements and then a many of them just start really good for people with cancer but this you're
asking you know what is a good supplement for your family well aloe vea came up with a product just
a couple of months ago called vitality and it's it's really one of the first whole food supplements
now there was some whole food supplements by garden of life and things but then garden of life got
bought out by bear or something like that and their supplements went downhill so it's really hard
to find a whole food supplement so this is one of the first whole food supplements now I've always
argued that you could just use greens first and greens first capsules for a basically whole food
nutritional source but vitality is a very specific supplementation that's whole food that you could
give your kids and your family everything is from a food source which there's just not really any
other supplements that I can recommend and people would ask I just want to take a multiple but I was
on the phone with a person of their family member you know want to just take a multiple and it's like
I don't have any choices for you so now we do so it's the aloevia vitality okay questions that you
chatted in my functional doctor want to be to run an estrogen metabolite panel from ZRT
that would show the four hydroxy metabolites the Dutch does not do that so the ZRT shows the following
and I'm not going to read all these off I guess it's the 4E2 ratio that looks bad from the report the
ratio is of two and four methylated hydroxyestergens the ratios of two and four methylated hydroxyestergens
that are within low to low normal reference ranges indicating that methylation of the hydroxyestergens
is poor how to help this I have to look at that lab so if you can forward that to me I'd appreciate that
in a call with my doctor this morning she introduced the idea metronomic chemotherapy that is 10%
of the normal strength I searched your site it didn't see a topic mentioned I would assume this
would have considerably reduced side effects we have been successful at keeping the prostate
tumor from spreading for about five years now but we don't seem to be making significant progress
at knocking it down and have avoided the toxic and invasive treatments thus far do you see metronomic
chemotherapy as a logical baby step in that direction so yeah you're just trying to think through
your option so number one metronomic or if you're using insulin to stimulate the uptake of it it's
called insulin-potentiated chemotherapy so you're giving a shot of insulin waiting for a period of
time and then doing 10% the dosage of chemotherapy well that idea first surfaced about 25 years ago
it was very exciting because if we could get the cancer cells to uptake the chemotherapy much more
efficiently could we not give a lower dose of chemotherapy well it had been proven to be successful
but the problem is it's not always successful like anything else first of all if chemotherapy isn't
going to if full dose chemotherapy isn't going to work for a person then then low dose chemotherapy
isn't going to work for the person and the truth is is that full dose chemotherapy only works for
a percentage of people so if the full dose is not going to work for you then the low doses
are going to work for you so chemotherapy is a drug that's increasing oxidative stress
what's problem is it doesn't work for everybody so it's then that's the struggle now with prostate
cancer I'm surprised they're offering that to you because prostate cancer historically
doesn't have a great success rate with chemotherapy it's not typically what is even recommended
unless they have run out of other options typically with prostate cancer they will recommend
antigen deprivation therapy which basically shuts down all your testosterone they'll recommend
possibly surgery possibly radiation and then they'll get down to chemotherapy so
it wouldn't be the first choice simply because there's a lower success rate with chemotherapy with
prostate cancer versus like breast cancer so but if I thought the chemotherapy was going to work
really well for me would it be wise to start with the lower dose chemotherapy yes it makes sense it
makes a lot of sense but there's negatives to that too so if you're going to do the lower dose chemotherapy
typically you have to do it much more frequently and you have to do many more sessions so while you
may not get the abrupt illness jumping right into full dose chemotherapy you can still lose your
hair you can still get really sick you can still it just will take over a greater length of time
so there's pros and cons to it so look into both those things and again if it's not if chemotherapy
isn't going to work for your cancer low dose chemotherapy is not going to work either you don't have
any greater success rate of that also the new teva makes a nice butter flavored organic coconut oil so
that's the comment for a person that is on dairy free diet thank you yeah and sometimes you know
just change what do we change our diet we're changing our habit patterns and that is sometimes
hard and we have change our taste buds for something as well okay any other questions all right thanks
everybody for being on remember you can self-schedule visit with me if you want otherwise get your
questions in and we will talk again next week everybody have a great day bye bye